good evening a unique day in American
history is ending a day set aside for a
nationwide outpouring of mankind seeking
its own survival birthday a day
dedicated to enlisting all the citizens
of a bountiful country in a common cause
of saving light from the deadly
byproducts of that copy I was CBS News
anchor Walter Cronkite of course hosting
a special broadcast on the very first
Earth Day back in nineteen seventy on
this 47th earth day concern for the
health of the planet has only grown a
CBS News poll this week found just
twelve percent believe the environment
will improve for the next generation
fifty-seven percent say it will get
worse today people around the world will
take part in the March for science as
some say respect for science is under
attack which could directly affect the
climate fight here to discuss it all is
dr. M sanjayan senior scientist at
Conservation International and host of
the new series climate lab on vox sunjin
good morning good morning so the large
for science right what's the ultimate
goal here I think it's to remind the
American people that scientists the only
objective mechanism we have to examine
data and to self-correct the progress
that we're making we don't in the
history of humanity we don't actually
have a system to do that so science
comes into our lives and the food we
have the technology we use I would take
care of the planet on a planet with
seven billion people it becomes really
important the only problem is scientists
are really bad at communicating and so I
gamma science you know and because we're
trained to be objective about data it is
bipartisan it is one of those things
that rarely that can actually unite
people around this this basic fact but
it's really hard to communicate and I
think science March is about reminding
the American public and the world that
science matters not I'm seeing a
surprising amount of enthusiasm not
surprising really but I mean a large
amount of enthusiasm among scientists
mathematicians doctors yeah for this
what do you look kind of turnout are you
expecting for them you know I've done a
science much before so we don't know but
there's at least
600 satellite marches like every town I
know the city i know some of my
colleagues are there marching and
they're going to bring the best sign
you'll see the best coffee can guarantee
SS sign some of them will go right over
everyone's heads but I think that's sort
of the point that's sort of the point
but are you concerned you know given how
fraught the national political
conversation is someone say partisanship
around science is the last thing we need
yeah well I don't actually see that this
is being partisan I think science as I
said it's one of those rare objective
looks at data and I think regardless of
your religion you raise your creed or
your political affiliation you ought to
be able to see the same data and and and
analyze it and then use the mechanism of
science yourself correct if that's the
great thing about science right it is
self-correcting right the minute you put
something out someone else is going to
try to find a way to improve on it and
that's why it survives that's why it's
been around it's been around since the
Greeks or even before that and to think
that we're going to defund it undefined
it ignore it and still find a way in
this incredibly fraught planet it's not
going to happen the White House is is
debating still the Paris agreement right
president Trump one of his campaign
promises was to cancel it can he
difficult it's actually difficult so the
great thing about the Paris agreement
was it was designed to be both flexible
and resilient flexible because each
country has its own way of approaching
this problem resilient because of
exactly challenges like this even if we
wanted to get out of it it would take
several years maybe three years or so
now what could happen and I actually
don't think the administration is going
to do that I really don't that's my
belief but it's not scientific does the
president attempt to unwind the Obama
era admission the Obama era clean power
plan doesn't that throw into doubt
whether the US can actually meet its
targets as outlined in thesaurus clan
what can happen is the u.s. can under
fund or defund its own commitment but
the problem with doing this is look the
train has left the station this is not a
problem that gets better
with age I promise you the whole world
is already on this the question is does
America want to lead or does it want to
follow with the leaders in science and
technology in ways of finding ways of
living on this planet better why give
that up now you have an exciting series
on Vox that everybody right to look at
the climate lab it is a must-see on the
internet well generally well generally
yes I see because it comes at this
problem in a different way deals with
the issues on climate change you know
irreverent in an irreverent way with
sort of different groups of people
alright I'm Sandra thank you very much
for being with us this morning again the
series is climate lab on boxes youtube
channel